okay you have an award now I've heard
these are quite heavy that's what they
always say right I can handle it
where is this one gonna go Oh somewhere
special listen I don't take these for
granted yeah I'm a little too emotional
I can't even talk right now Nicole
Kidman just gave me an award in love
with her I never thought that I would
have this career you know and that's
really the truth and so I think every
actor always longs for longevity we
tried to stay in this game for a long
time and the fact that I've been able to
do it not only for this long but on my
own terms and and the stuff that I
really the stuff that matters to me like
that means a lot the fact that I can
really look back on my life and feel
like I did something that I really
wanted to do means a lot were you
tearing up while she was speaking about
you yes oh my god I mean she's just she
to me is such an icon and somebody that
I so respect and admire and for her to
say all of those things and first
finally to be in a film together and and
not just the film it's something that
I'm incredibly proud of that I think is
incredibly important and to share that
with her it means a lot I do I'm not
taking it off we're just one to ask have
you got a chance to see morning show yet
because so many of these important
stories are being told I have not I have
literally been working incredibly hard
to get people to see my movie but I will
get to that show I love those girls I
think they're amazing and Mark Duplass
is in it who's in our film who I
absolutely love his family
the trailers insane yeah yeah I wish
song couldn't be more perfect
thank you thank you
[Music]